Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 175. Hallo, hier ist Tim Prittlarf und ihr lauscht einer Folge, die sich ganz offensichtlich der Kultur widmet und es geht mal wieder um die Hackerkultur und wir wollen mal einen Aspekt beleuchten, der hier bisher viel zu kurz gekommen ist. Beziehungsweise es gab schon mal eine Sendung, die das schon mal leicht angekratzt hat, aber diesmal gehen wir hier in die Vollen. Es geht um Hackerbrausen oder vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter aufgeklappt. Es geht so generell eigentlich so um die Ernährung der hackenden Front und ja, dazu habe ich mir gleich zwei Super-Experten geholt und zwar einerseits Jens Ohlig. Wir haben ja schon mal hier die ganz tolle, ganz tollen CRE gemacht, bin immer noch ganz begeistert. Die Internetmeme-Sendung war echt insightful, sagt man, glaube ich, heutzutage. Und außerdem Sebastian Vollnhals, genannt Jetzt. Jetzt musst du Hallo sagen.
Hallo.
Jetzt hat jetzt Hallo gesagt.
Jetzt mit Y.
Genau.
Falls das jetzt einer eintippen möchte, nicht dass er sich vertippt. Ja, und ihr habt euch mal aufgerafft und habt mal geblockt. Wir bloggen schon seit geraumer Zeit. Also nicht nur wir beide. Gibt noch mindestens eine weitere Mitstreiterin, die Katrin aus Hamburg, der Hackerbrausen, Hauptstadt, kann man so sagen, ja. Und dann gibt es halt auch noch Leute, die immer wieder mal behaupten, sie würden auch sich mal beteiligen, aber das ist noch nicht passiert. Das ist noch nicht passiert. Aber wir haben einen Blog, wo es nur um koffeinhaltige Erfrischungsgetränke geht und um die Kultur, die mit koffeinhaltigen Erfrischungsgetränken verbunden ist. Und das heißt natürlich hackerbrause.de. hackerbrause.de, das gibt es jetzt auch schon eine Weile, ne? Ich glaube ein, zwei Jahre.
Zwei Jahre sind es ungefähr.
Also die Idee gab es noch schon länger und dann irgendwann vor zwei Jahren im Sommer haben wir dann gesagt, okay, das muss jetzt einfach sein. Domain registriert und jetzt hatte dann den Server am Start und hat das WordPress aufgesetzt und zack.
Genau. War so eine laune Aktion irgendwie.
Hat aber ganz gut getragen.
Ja, also es ist erstaunlich. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, dass ich hatte eigentlich immer schon mal vor, das zu machen und ja, die Leute haben mich öfter mal gefragt, macht doch so mal was und dann habe ich einfach mal auf Twitter darum gefragt, wer denn dazu noch Lust hätte und der Joel meinte, ja hier, hier, hier und dann haben wir das einfach mal so gemacht aus der hohen Hand.
Genau, also das muss man auch dazu sagen, als wir angefangen haben dieses Blog zu starten, hatten wir uns noch nicht getroffen. Also wir wussten, dass wir jeweils existieren, aber wir sind uns einmal ganz kurz auf der Ferne mal zugewunken.
Genau, wir haben uns einmal ganz kurz auf der Ferne zugewunken, auf dem Kongress.
Aber gut, aber heute ist nicht das erste Mal, dass ihr euch live seht, so ist es auch nicht. Aber ja, Hacker und ihre Ernährung und die Sonderstellung der Getränke, das ist so ein Phänomen, dem muss jetzt einfach langsam mal auf die Spur gegangen werden. Deswegen diese Sendung. Ich meine, da gibt es ja echt eine Menge Klischees und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob nicht vielleicht die meisten davon sogar zutreffen. Nicht wahr? So die durchgehackten Nächte, der Hacker, er und seine Tastatur und dann steht halt immer so ein Dopingmittel auf dem Tisch.
Hacker und Bewusstseins erweitern die Substanz im Allgemeinen.
Damit hat es eigentlich mal angefangen. Ich glaube, früher hat es mehr diesen Mythos gehabt, die nehmen ja alle Drogen. Also wenn man halt so Sachen wie das Jagung-Fall durchliest, da gibt es auch tatsächlich einen Abschnitt zu Hacker-Enährung und es gibt auch einen Abschnitt zu Ceremonial Chemicals, also Chemie, die man irgendwie zum Spaß einnehmen kann. Da gehört Koffein sicherlich auch dazu, aber auch diverse andere Sachen. Und dann gibt es halt Sachen, die eher selten so bei Hackern sind. Also ich denke mal, ein großer Unterschied, der zum Beispiel auch zwischen dem Chaos-Communication-Kongress oder irgendwelchen Demo-Coda-Veranstaltungen, die es ja auch gibt, ist halt wirklich die Menge des verzehrten Alkohols. Die dürfte wesentlich geringer im CCC-Umfeld sein als bei diesen harten Democodern oder sowas.
Es gibt ja auch das klassische Bild des Coding-Monkeys, der morgens nur mit einer Tasse Kaffee irgendwie überhaupt aus dem Bett kommt. Und in großen Firmen ist auch die Kaffeemaschine so derzentale Ort, um den sich ganz viel abspielt und dass da ein Substanzen-Gebrauch in Form von Koffein für ihn quasi an der Tagesordnung ist, bei Leuten, die was mit Informatik zu tun haben, ist ja eigentlich bekannt.
Auch bei mir, als ich angefangen habe, das Usenet zu entdecken, war, glaube ich, so eine der ersten Newsgruppen, die ich abonniert habe, Alt-Fan-Café. Und ja, das gehört irgendwie dazu, von Anfang an, wie, was weiß ich, Vorliebe für Science-Fiction-Literatur oder Lust an Sprachspielen oder sowas, da gehört irgendwie die Lust am Koffein halt auch dazu, was vielleicht irgendwie damit zu tun hat. So richtig kann ich es irgendwie nicht erklären, aber ja, man arbeitet ja halt auch länger und nachts und da muss man sich irgendwie wach halten. Und Zucker und Koffein sind da halt irgendwie Dinge, die irgendwie schnell das Gehirn wach machen. Ja, ja, ich hatte ja hier auch schon, Ausgabe 119 hat sich ja dem Kaffee gewidmet, eine Sendung, auf die man gar nicht wahrscheinlich groß verweisen muss, weil ich so den Eindruck gehabt habe, die hat sowieso jeder gehört, zumindest macht sich das im Feedback immer so fest. Und ich denke, der Grund dafür ist eben auch, dass da die Affinität sich einfach zum Koffein mal so ein bisschen badenbrechen konnte. Ich überlege gerade, wie ich das eigentlich so damals so gehalten habe, so mit den Nächten und dass ich jetzt ausgesprochen viel Kaffee getrunken habe, kann ich mich gar nicht daran erinnern, aber es könnte natürlich sein, dass ich Cola getrunken habe. Ja, wir hatten ja nichts, also wir haben ja Cola getrunken.
Genau. Und auch keine richtig gute, weil gab es damals noch nicht so wirklich. Afri-Cola war damals noch gut. Das kommt ja quasi aus, Afri-Cola war quasi die deutsche Alternative zu Coca-Cola. Aber später wurde dann diese Afri-Cola, ist ja zusammen mit Bluna, und das wurde dann an einen großen internationalen Konzern oder Getränkekonzern irgendwie verkauft. Und dann haben sie einfach das Coca-Cola easiert und haben den Zucker hochgedreht und das Koffein drunter. Und damit war die quasi unbrauchbar gemacht worden.
Also Afri-Cola hat durchaus irgendwie mal reizvoll angefangen. Die hatten irgendwie früher diesen Werbespruch der gute Rausch und haben da auch mit geworben. Aber ich meine Coca-Cola ist ja auch schon mal so interessant, weil ja auch Coca-Cola irgendwann gar nicht mal auf Basis von Koffein funktioniert hat, sondern eben auf Coca. Also eigentlich war es ja, oder ist das alles ein Gerücht?
Das ist, da gibt es wilde Geschichten, wilde Gerüchte und das ist auch alles nicht mehr so ganz hundertprozentig nachvollziehbar. Ursprünglich, also ganz zurück an den Anfang gegangen, gibt es ja diesen Vin Mariani, was im Prinzip so eine Arznei war und da war eben Kokain drin und das hat man damals irgendwie verordnet für Leute, die sich nicht konzentrieren können und die irgendwie etwas Belebendes haben wollten.
Vin Mariani.
Genau. Und das war so das erste Produkt zu dieser Zeit. Damals wusste man über Kokain noch gar nichts und später hat dann auch ein Apotheker so eine Substanz zusammengemischt. Das war so in dieser Welle, als Kokain ein relativ beliebter Arznei war und hat da Cola, Nuss und Koffein und Coca-Blätter also irgendwie reingemischt und hat das halt Coca-Cola genannt. War am Anfang quasi so ein dickflüssiger, zäher Sirup und das haben sich halt viele Leute gekauft. Also es ist nicht mehr so ganz klar, ob da jetzt wirklich Koffein, Kokain drin war. Das lässt sich nicht mal so klein nachvollziehen, vor allem weil da irgendwie dieses Rezept, was er verwendet hat, natürlich auch geheim war, um sich vor irgendwelchen Nachahmern zu schützen. Was auf jeden Fall passiert ist, ist dass bzw. was damals auf jeden Fall war, war, dass der Koffeingehalt in dem Getränk sehr, sehr viel höher war als heute. Also irgendwie ungefähr so die zehnfache Dosis dessen, was da heute drin ist. Also eigentlich schon eine ganz schöne Menge. Und ja, als man dann so rausgefunden hat, wie dieses Kokain wirkt, haben die halt einen Trick angewandt, damit sie diesen Markenrechte für diesen Namen Coca-Cola weiterhalten dürfen, haben sie einfach ein anderes Rotholz gewächst, was auch irgendwie Coca heißt, aber eben nicht diesen Drogenwirkstoff drin hat, irgendwie ins Rezept reingemischt und das dann einfach nur noch so als Erfischungsgetränk verkauft und sich gar nicht mehr so oft auf diese Arzneiwirkung reduziert.
Wir reden jetzt noch von 1800 irgendwas, oder? Ja, wobei also der Genuss von Coca-Blättern oder so ist ja weitaus älter.
Ja, das ist weitaus älter. Das ist quasi in der ganzen Kultur in Lateinamerika und Südamerika schon verwurzelt, da wo das Zeug halt wächst. Aber dass es eben dann quasi auch in die westliche Zivilisation gekommen ist, das war so um die Jahrhundertwende. Ich glaube, 1890 rum ist eben Coca-Cola auf den Markt gekommen oder erfunden worden.
Und gibt es irgendwie heute noch, aber das, was wir heute als Coca-Cola kennen, hat mit dem natürlich nicht mehr so richtig viel zu tun? Ja, mittlerweile auch mehrmals verändert worden im Rezept und es gibt irgendwie mittlerweile Coca-Cola Light mit interessanten Nebenwirkungen oder so. Also hört man ja immer wieder, dass das zum Beispiel auch als Verhütungsmittel benutzt wird. Coca-Cola Light kann halt... Als Verhütungsmittel?
Das ist ein Spermizid.
Spermizid kann... Muss man sich das dann irgendwo rübergießen oder... Als Dusche danach vielleicht?
Don't try this at home.
Oder reicht jetzt trinken auch schon? Nee, nee, trinken reicht auch nicht. Das sind die Cola-Getränke. Daran denkt man auch als erstes, wenn man über Hackerbrausen nachdenkt, dass man dann an Coca-Cola denkt oder Pepsi.
Coca-Cola ist quasi so der Archetyp der Cola-Getränke. Ganz viele Gerüchte lagen sich auch darum, was da jetzt eigentlich drin ist. Also was ganz klar ist, was da drin ist, sind so die Sachen, die auf der Zutatel-Liste stehen, so Wasser, Zucker, Zitronensäure oder Phosphorsäure, je nachdem.
Du bist jetzt noch bei Coca-Cola.
Ich bin noch bei Coca-Cola, ja. Dann Koffein ist natürlich dann aber dieser Getränke-Grundstoff, der was eigentlich diesen Geschmack ausmacht. Darüber ranken sich auch ziemliche Geheimnisse. Angeblich ist das auf einem Pergament aufgeschrieben, was irgendwo im Safe der Coca-Cola-Company im Keller liegt. Da gibt es die wildesten Gerüchte, was man aber weiß, was da drin ist, sind halt so Sachen wie, das sind ganz viele ätherische Öle, sprich Vanilleöl, Zimtöl, Nelkenöl, Zitronen- oder Limettenöl und dann noch irgendwelche anderen lustigen Kräutersachen. Also das ist eigentlich, wenn man es drauf zurückführt, ist das eigentlich eine Kräuterlimonade, so eine Coca-Cola.
Interessante Variante. Mittlerweile gibt es Cola dann auch wirklich echt überall und in allen Ländern der Welt. Also zum Teil halt auch... Also, ich meine, dass dieses Rezept jetzt gänzlich unbekannt wäre, ist ja wohl ein Gerücht. Ich meine, heutzutage kann man die Zusammensetzung, aber die Zusammensetzung lässt sich doch bestimmt heute chemisch so weit rekonstruieren, dass wir das jetzt sozusagen wirklich rausfinden, weil es auch rausfindet.
Ja, wenn du ein Labor hast, dann kannst du dir das natürlich angucken, denke ich mal. Also es gibt auch Leute, die quasi so ein Rezept reverse-ingeniert haben, und die das Ganze dann Open-Cola nennen, zum Zuhause so selbst zusammenbauen.
Echt Open-Cola. Also, es ist vielleicht auch eine interessante Sache. Schmeckt gut, denn es ist open. Was ist halt alles so, also Coca-Cola steht ja auch für was, also es ist halt ja wahrscheinlich so eine der Marken, die am deutlichsten halt für die Globalisierung stehen. Nach dem Big Mac. Ja, also schon bevor es Globalisierung gab, quasi schon. Jaja. Überall gab es Coca-Cola und so und deswegen gab es halt auch irgendwie ganz schnell auch Leute, die gesagt haben, das finden wir nicht gut und das ist ja alles irgendwie böse amerikanischer Imperialismus und so weiter. Es gibt zum Beispiel die Mecca-Cola, die im Nahen Osten verkauft wird. Ach so, Mecca wie? Für gute Moslems. Es gibt Cola-Turka, sieht man auch hier häufiger mal bei Dönerbuden. Ach so, türkische Cola. Ist das dann so wie das Äquivalent zu türkischer Pizza?
Es gibt auch eine kubanische Cola.
Ach, kubanisch? Was haben wir noch? Was ist das dann? Das ist dann sozusagen Cola ohne Cola.
Ja, das ist quasi so, wir sind hier in Kuba und haben unser Handelsimbago und da bauen wir einfach mal irgendwie eine Cola nach, die wir dann auch selbst verkaufen können an die Touristen. Und ja, ich weiß aber gar nicht mehr, wie die heißt.
Ich war ja mal in Kuba, ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich da irgendwie sowas getrunken? Ja gut, vielleicht war das da drin.
Ja, wie ist es mit Coca-Cola traditionell?
Ja, in Deutschland gibt es halt irgendwie erstaunlich viele Cola-Sorten. Afri-Cola hatten wir schon, Fritz-Cola aus der Hackerbrausen Hauptstadt Hamburg, Vita-Cola, Schlucki-Cola aus Franken, Club-Cola, genau. Mal langsam. Also Cola-Hauptstadt Hamburg, warum? Weil da einfach ganz, ganz, ganz oder Cola-Hauptstadt, also Hauptstadt der Hackerbrausen, würde ich einfach mal sagen, der koffeinhaltigen Erfrischungsgetränke, weil unheimlich viele Sorten aus Hamburg einfach kommen. Gibt es da eine Erklärung für?
In Hamburg ist einfach unglaublich viel kreatives Potenzial von Leuten, die irgendwie Lust haben, sich ein eigenes Getränk zusammen zu basteln.
Ja, vielleicht ist das eine Erklärung. Vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur Zufall. Vielleicht hat das auch was mit dem Hafen zu tun. Also es ist zumindest so, dass da halt auch wirklich irgendwie sehr lokal spezifische Werbung gemacht wird. Wenn man halt auf der Schanze in Hamburg steht, gegenüber von der Roten Flora, dann lächelt einem so eine Fritz-Cola-Reklame an, wo drauf steht, nur Wasserwerfer machen wacher. In Hamburg gibt es auch Clubs, die ihre eigene Cola-Marke haben.
Zum Beispiel Mojo-Cola vom Mojo-Club.
Richtig. Ich erinnere mich, war nicht sogar auch, ich glaube es kam auch aus Hamburg, Premium-Cola, war das nicht sogar fast die erste dieser ganzen Colas und die auch explizit noch mal dieses uralte Afri-Cola Rezept aufgegriffen hat? Premium-Cola hat eine sehr, sehr interessante Geschichte. Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht eine der ersten, sondern es ist genau. Also sie beziehen sich auf dieses alte Afri-Cola Rezept und dann ist was Interessantes passiert.
Ja, also im Prinzip ist es quasi entstanden dadurch, dass Afri-Cola irgendwann mal kokalisiert wurde, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, sodass sie einfach mehr Zucker und weniger Koffein reingekippt hat. Und dann gab es einfach ein paar Menschen, die gesagt haben, irgendwie haben wir da keinen Bock drauf und das war so um die Jahrtausendwende, Ende des letzten, Anfang dieses Jahrhunderts. Die haben sich im Internet zusammengefunden und haben dort quasi eine Interessengruppe gewöhnt, die Interessengruppe Premium und haben jahrelang irgendwie versucht, irgendwie Afri-Cola davon zu überzeugen, wieder ihre Premium-Sorte Afri herzustellen.
Das war ja auch so eine Zeit, wo es eigentlich, also ich weiß nicht, wir reden so von 1998, 1999 war das so was. Da kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern, dass es jetzt überhaupt Alternativen gegeben hätte. Also vielleicht gab es schon welche, aber dass die jetzt einen nennenswerten Bekanntheitsgrad gehabt hatten.
Ja, so die deutsche Alternative war halt immer Afri-Cola. Die haben wir halt hier bekommen und mit der konnte man irgendwie schön wach bleiben und die gab es dann einfach nicht mehr. Und dann, wie gesagt, haben sich ein paar Leute zusammengefunden und haben dann ein bisschen versucht, Lobbyarbeit zu betreiben dahingehend und haben sich quasi über die oder unter diesem Anlass zusammengefunden und irgendwann hatte sich ergeben, dass jemanden aus dieser Gruppe das alte Afri-Cola-Rezept, das da wohl noch bei so einem alten Braumeister oder so irgendeiner Fabrik, die das mal hergestellt hat, irgendwie unterm Kopfkissen oder im Gift-Shank oder weiß ja gar wo das aufgetaucht ist. Und mit diesem Rezept in der Hand haben sie natürlich irgendwie sofort das gemacht, was man so macht. Sie haben sich erstmal so eine fure originale Afri-Cola herstellen lassen und ich glaube, sie hatten da irgendwie ein paar Paletten, also nicht nennenswert viel und war auch reges Interesse damals da und das war schnell weg. Und ich glaube, das hat die Menschen dann dazu veranlasst zu sagen, hey, da gibt es Bedarf, da ist irgendwie eine coole Cola-Sorte, die wir alle haben wollen und da gibt es bestimmt noch andere Menschen, die die haben wollen, lass uns da mal einsteigen. Und daraufhin haben die irgendwie ganz viel richtig gemacht. Sie haben nicht gesagt, ja dann künden wir in eine Firma und verkloppen das jetzt zu möglichst viel Geld, sondern sie haben gesagt, hey, lass uns das irgendwie mal cool organisieren und gucken, was man da sonst noch irgendwie alles besser machen kann. Und daraus ist eben diese ja, Premium-Cola entstanden.
Die sprechen ja auch von einem Betriebssystem, Premium-Cola. Also wenn man halt Teil von diesem Betriebssystem sein möchte, dann kann man sich da auch auf eine Mailing-Liste subscribieren. Es wird da irgendwie kein richtiger Unterschied gemacht zwischen den Leuten, die am Produktionsprozess beteiligt sind. Also es gibt nicht die Konsumenten auf der einen Seite und die Produzenten auf der anderen, sondern es wird irgendwie versucht, alles Cola-Communismus.
Sozusagen. Also es ist ein riesiges, quasi genossenschaftliches Konzept, das die Leute da fahren. Und das ist eigentlich auch eine ziemlich spannende Sache. Also da geht es nicht darum, irgendwie nach marktwirtschaftlichen Kriterien Cola zu produzieren, sondern eben viel mehr zu machen. Eben auch zu gucken, dass das Ganze nachhaltig ist, dass man auch seine Konsumenten mit einbezieht, dass man vielleicht irgendwelche kleineren Verkaufsstellen mehr fördert als irgendwelche großen Ketten.
Mit Abstimmung über nächste Verkaufsstellen auf der Mailing-Liste und allem pipapo. Also auch mit Demokratie. Ja, soweit das halt in so einem Rahmen möglich ist.
Genau, also das ist eine super spannende Sache. Also es gibt zum Beispiel auch diesen Anti-Rabatt, dass irgendwie kleine Läden zahlen irgendwie weniger als irgendwie große Supermärkte beim Einkauf bzw. je mehr du quasi einkaufst, desto teurer wird es pro Einheit. Also das ist schon eine ziemlich spannende Sache und es scheint auch ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Und kommt natürlich aus Hamburg, also ist auch irgendwie stark verwurzelt. Und ja, die interessante Entwicklung, die im letzten Jahr gestartet ist, war, dass sich andere Leute dann halt auch aufgemacht haben wollten, eine weitere Hackerbrause kreieren, eine ganz elitäre Hackerbrause, die Lead-Mate und die sind auch ziemlich schnell dann halt auch zu Premium gekommen. Also Lead-Mate ist nicht von Premium oder so, kann man nicht sagen, dass das irgendwie so ist, wie eine Firma ist, aber es ist von Anfang an halt viel unter die Arme gegriffen worden und das ganze Konzept. Das heißt, in diesem Kollektiv-Premium werden überhaupt Getränke irgendwie, ja, auch nicht unbedingt produziert, aber so ersonnen und vermarktet.
Nee, es ist quasi so, dass sie ihr Know-how und jede Infrastruktur ein bisschen zur Verfügung stellen für irgendwelche Leute, die selber was auf die Beine stellen wollen.
Also die Lied-Mate kommt von den Lied-Mate-Erfindern und da waren einfach irgendwie zwei, drei Jungs, die vorher irgendwie eine Web-Agentur, glaube ich, betrieben haben, die wollten einfach ihre eigene Mate machen und dann, ja, da man halt irgendwie auch in Hamburg ansässig war, hat man sich dann halt mit Premium kurz geschlossen und hat dann viele Ideen von denen übernommen. So, jetzt hattet ihr noch so ein paar andere, also vielleicht sollten wir noch mal so kurz bei der Cola noch bleiben, bevor wir dann das Kapitel der Mate aufschlagen. Hat jetzt vorhin so eine ganze Reihe von Cola-Varianten noch runtergerattert. Club-Cola ist ja quasi die alte Ost-Cola, oder?
Na, da gab es zwei. Club-Cola und Vita-Cola.
Genau. Und inwiefern sind die heute noch das, was sie mal waren?
Teilweise. Also das ist ganz schwierig. Club-Cola war immer so ein bisschen, dass wir bauen Coca-Cola nach, während Vita-Cola so, dass wir machen unser eigenes Ding mit einem ganz eigenen Geschmack.
Das war sehr citrushaltig.
Genau. Also wer die Vita-Cola mal probiert hat, die schmeckt einfach nicht, das nicht nach dem, wie man es erwarten würde von der Cola. Inwiefern das heute noch ganz original ist, kann ich nicht so genau sagen, weil ich eben die Originalprodukte nicht mal probiert habe.
Ich kann mich mal erinnern, irgendwie 88 oder so habe ich, glaube ich, mal der DDR irgendwo im Club Cola getrunken oder zumindest wurde es mir als solches da gereicht und naja, also für meine Festzunge war das dann in dem Moment nicht so einfach. Also ich glaube, dass man kann da wirklich auch einen geschichtlichen Strich ungefähr um die Zeit machen. Also es ist alles so eine Sache der frühen 90er Jahre. Also da sind ganz viele Sachen zusammengekommen. Da ist irgendwie die Wiedervereinigung gekommen, da hatte man halt die die Osthackerbrausen. Es ist dazu gekommen, dass ja dann irgendwie Mitte der 90er Jahre mussten dann halt auch ja wegen EU und so weiter alle Lebensmittel, die irgendwo in der EU zugelassen waren, mussten dann halt auch in Deutschland zugelassen sein. Dadurch hatten wir dann halt nicht nur im Skiurlaub, sondern halt auch ganzjährig Red Bull plötzlich in den Regalen. Also diese ganzen Energydrinks kamen dann halt dazu. Das hat sich dann auch noch wunderbar mit dieser ganzen Technokultur verrührt. Ganz genau. Und dann halt also ganze Nacht irgendwie aufbleiben und tanzen oder hacken. Und irgendwie, da gab es den Urknall. Also, dass man Koffein konsumiert hat, das war sicherlich schon vorher. Aber Cola war dann eigentlich gar nicht so sehr das Ding. Sondern da kamen ja dann auch so andere Sachen. Guarana hatte da irgendwie so eine totale Hochphase Anfang der 90er. Alle möglichen Getränke damit. Wobei Red Bull ist ja dann nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Ja, Red Bull hat dieses Taurin drin, wo man dann sagt, das kommt aus Stierhoden oder so was. Aber ich denke, der Name ist halt einfach eher mehr so ein Werbegag. Ja, kam halt aus Österreich und war irgendwie zumindest für mich als Westdeutschen war das immer so ein bisschen sagenumwoben. Das ist in Österreich legal, aber bei uns ist das total verboten, weil das wahnsinnig viel Koffein und sowas enthält.
Heute tatsächlich noch so, dass in Österreich die Grenzwerte für Koffein-Gehalt in Erfüllungsgetränken ein bisschen anders sind. Also da ist ein bisschen mehr zulässig als in Deutschland.
Vielleicht eine Folge der Kaffeehauskultur, wer weiß. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, viel Koffein, wenig Koffein, wovon reden wir denn dann eigentlich? Also ich meine, was sind denn diese Nenemengen und was ist denn wenig und was ist denn viel?
Na, in Coca-Cola sind zum Beispiel 10 Milligramm pro 100 Milliliter drin. Das in Deutschland maximal Erlaubte sind irgendwie 25 Milligramm pro 100 Milliliter in koffeinhaltigen Genuss- und Erfrischungsgetränken. Und wenn du das Ganze quasi als Energy-Drink, also nicht mehr als Erfrischungsgetränk, vermarktest, dann darfst du 32 Milligramm pro 100 Milliliter rein tun. Und ab 15 Milligramm pro 100 Milliliter musst du es kennzeichnen, wie viel drin ist.
Und wie würdet ihr so die Wirkung dieser Mengen einschätzen? Gut. Ich meine, das kann man knapp zu sagen. Wann fängt man an zu zittern? Welche Menge kann denn der Körper verkraften?
Da ist ganz viel auch Gewohnheit dabei. Das Koffein wirkt ja so, dass sich das quasi im Gehirn andockt an irgendwelche Rezepturen. Beziehungsweise das Gehirn schüttet normalerweise einen Botenstoff, Adenosin, aus und der hat auch Rezepturen. Wenn diese Rezepturen voll sind, dann wirst du müde. Während das Koffein sorgt sich auch an diese Rezepturen an, aber ohne dass es diese Müdigkeitswirkung hat. Dann kann das Adenosin nicht mehr andocken und dann wirst du nicht mehr müde. Oder das dauert länger, bis sich das Koffein wieder abgebaut hat. Die Sache ist, dass dein Gehirn dann einfach mehr Rezepturen ausbildet und quasi auch mit dem Gebrauch von Koffein bildest du quasi auch eine Toleranz aus. So ist das immer ganz schwer einzuschätzen.
Also Koffeintoleranz kennt glaube ich fast jeder. Ja. Das ist einfach echt nicht mehr zu vermeiden. Wenn man zu viel Koffein konsumiert, dann ist irgendwann Schicht. Und da muss man einfach mal eine Woche Pause machen oder so, damit sich das Ganze dann wieder halt normalisiert und dass man wieder auf das Koffein anspringt. Und man hat auch tatsächlich, naja, ganz leichte Entzugerscheinungen während dieser Zeit. Also viele Leute sind dann ein bisschen krummelig und so, wenn sie keinen Koffein mehr bekommen.
Deswegen kann man es irgendwie ganz schwer einschätzen, so welche Menge jetzt die ist, die den optimalsten Effekt hat. Sondern das muss jeder für sich einschätzen. So wenn ich jeden Tag meine zwei Liter Kaffee trinke, dann brauche ich nicht irgendwie mit einem Red Bull anzukommen und glauben, dass es mir dann wieder gut geht.
Abgesehen davon, also es gibt noch mehr Sachen. Sicherlich gibt es halt auch noch den Placebo-Effekt, nicht zu unterschätzen. Und dann ist halt das andere, was einen bei diesen Getränken aufputscht, das ist halt immer auch noch der Zucker. Also da gibt es Getränke, die sind irgendwie mit mehr Zucker und mit weniger Zucker. Und was dann irgendwie wieder diese Sagen oder sowas, wie wir es halt irgendwie mit Red Bull hatten. In Amerika zum Beispiel ist aus politischen Gründen fast alles mit diesem Mais-Sirup gemacht. High fructose corn-Sirup, weil der Mais-Abbau sehr subventioniert wird und die meisten Amerikaner kennen nicht zuckerhaltige Getränke, also Cola oder sowas. Deswegen ist auch zum Beispiel mexikanische Cola, wenn man sie in den USA mal kriegt, heiß begehrt. Oder es gibt ums Passa-Fest rum Koschere Cola, auch mit Zucker gemacht, die ist auch immer sehr beliebt. Da wird auch ein Riesenkult rumgemacht. Das ist Cola mit echtem Zucker, das ist nicht mit Mais-Sirup. Aber das haben wir in Europa eigentlich gar nicht, oder?
Wir haben grundsätzlich Zucker mit Mais-Sirup, einfach weil es hier mehr subventioniert ist und einfach mehr angebaut wird.
Und, Geschmackunterschiede? Hast du da irgendwas feststellen können?
Schmeckt pappiger.
Ja, es schmeckt nicht so gut. Wichtiger Zucker schmeckt ein bisschen besser. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch nur Gewöhnungssache. Das denke ich auch so, ja. Also wenn man es halt nicht anders kennt. Aber der gemeine Amerikaner, wenn er sich in Europa rumtreibt, der kriegt dann auch erstmal einen Schock, dass die Cola anders schmeckt. Ja, oder es ist halt auch zum Teil, glaube ich, Einbildung. Ja, Euro-Coke, die mexikanische Cola, die gesucht wird und die man auch häufiger findet und so. Also es gab halt auch eine Cola-Sorte, die für die Hacker-Szene relativ bedeutend war. Jolt Cola in den USA, genau. Und die hatten lange Zeit den Werbespruch All the sugar, twice the caffeine.
Genau, sie hatten einfach doppelt so viel Koffein wie Coca-Cola und richtigen Zucker drin und waren damit prädestiniert für irgendwelche Computernerts, das Mittel dabei zu sein.
Selbst das mussten sie irgendwann abschaffen, weil sie halt auch auf Mais-Sirup umgestellt haben.
Also doppeltes Koffein heißt an der Stelle auch 20 Milligramm 100 Milliliter und das ist so viel wie Club Martel hat.
Also sozusagen deswegen hat Jolt Cola, also ist das eigentlich nur so eine nachgesagte Popularität in der amerikanischen Hacker-Szene oder fand die auch statt? Also ich kann mich da auf jeden Fall daran erinnern, dass das so Anfang der 90er nicht nur in Amerika, auch hier bei uns in Europa, da gab es diese Camps in Holland, wo man sich dann irgendwie alle vier Jahre getroffen hat, um auf dem Acker zu hacken und da war Jolt Cola irgendwie das Ding. Also zumindest beim Camp 1993, weiß ich das noch.
Da gab es Jolt-Fandkuchen. Ich war nicht dabei, ich habe es nur in dem Video gesehen.
Ich versuche mich gerade zu erinnern. Also ich weiß noch, wir hatten das auf unserem Camp, auf unserem ersten 99 hatten wir es auch. Was aber vor allem daran lag, dass die halt von Jolt da auch echt hinterher waren. Die haben es einem förmlich aufgetragen. Die haben das irgendwann auch wirklich mitgekriegt, dass sie da halt irgendwie so einen bestimmten Beruf haben. Es gibt auch irgendwie einen Software-Award, also die Jolt-Awards für Software-Bücher und so weiter. Da achten die halt drauf. Ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass bei den Veranstaltungen, die in New York immer stattfinden, diese von 2600, diese HOPE-Dinger, da gab es auch ein wahnsinniges Sponsoring von Jolt, bis die Amerikaner halt auch auf die helle Seite der Macht gekommen sind und Club-Mate für sich entdeckt haben. Ja, das ist ja sozusagen das Phänomen und irgendwie wissen wir ja alle, Club-Mate spielt irgendwie eine besondere Rolle. Was ist denn so, habt ihr euch da so ein bisschen intensiver mit der Geschichte beschäftigt jetzt aufgrund von Hackerbrause oder habt ihr schon immer drin gesteckt? Ich meine, ich weiß so einiges, aber ich will nicht für mich in Anspruch nehmen, dass ich jetzt so das letzte Detail da auch ergründet habe.
Club-Mate ist irgendwie so eine Hackerbrause by accident, kann man sagen. Es ist ein Getränk, das irgendwo aus der fränkischen Provinz kommt, das da halt irgendwie auch nicht besonders populär war und es ist glaube ich reinen Zufall geschuldet, dass das jetzt so das Ding ist.
Zufall meinst du? Ich weiß nicht, ob es direkt Zufall ist oder ob da einfach viele Sachen auf ganz wunderliche Art und Weise zusammengefallen sind. Also es ist halt auch wieder populär geworden, genau um diese Zeit, so 90er Jahre irgendwas. Und auch da gab es halt den großen Umbruch. Ja, das war halt so diese Zeit, wo zumindest irgendwie in Berlin es dann so war, dass es ganze Straßen gab mit unklarer Rechtslage, weil die Bewohner waren abgehauen und dann hat man irgendwie die Tür aufgemacht, den Schritt weggeräumt, Soundanlage hingestellt und fertig war der Techno-Club und so. Und da brauchte man auf jeden Fall dann auch Unterstützung für die Tanznächte und so. Und da halt in Berlin niemand wirklich aus Berlin kommt, sondern immer irgendwo her und halt dann auch gerne mal außer Provinz. Stimmt, das ist eine gute Theorie. Also ich meine, ich erinnere mich noch, es gab ja hier in Berlin, ich weiß gar nicht, also ob das jetzt wirklich so ist, dass das von Berlin ausging. Das ist natürlich, wenn man jetzt in Berlin wohnt und das hier so mitbekommen hat, immer so ein bisschen so die naheliegende Erklärung. Aber es gab ja hier und gibt auch immer noch jemanden, der heißt Marte Ralf. Und Marte Ralf hatte in Mitte so ein Club, ich habe leider den Namen vergessen, Clubforschung. Und der hat irgendwie dieses Zeug angeschleppt. Und in seinem Laden gab es halt alles mit Club Marte. Und er ist ja auch derjenige, der dann immer runtergefahren ist zu Loscher, also der Loscher KG, dem Hersteller von Club Marte, die das ja seinerzeit auch nur aufgekauft haben. Also wie hieß denn überhaupt diese ursprüngliche Bude, die er erst mal erfunden hat? Wie die ursprüngliche Bude hat, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, aber ich weiß es, also es kam halt auch aus dieser fränkischen Ecke von einer kleineren Bauerei und hieß bis in die 50er Jahre Brunte. Sect Bronte. Sect Bronte. Club Marte heißt es eigentlich erst seit 1990. Und ja, seitdem gibt es das halt auch erst in der Form, wie wir sie kennen. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, da müsste man echt mal fragen. Ich bin neulich mal über den Weg gelaufen, aber da bin ich irgendwie in dem Moment nicht auf die Idee gekommen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz, ganz klar so eine Sache aus dieser Wilgen-Berlin-Zeit. Genau, weil diese Clubforschung, die war halt keine 100 Meter entfernt von der Sea-Base. Das war halt da hackischer Markt, unmittelbar um die Ecke und man hat halt häufig auch in dieser Bar abgehangen und er hat ja damals schon das auch schon vollständig kultiviert gehabt. Also er hat ja nicht nur Club-Mate im Angebot gehabt, sondern hat quasi alle möglichen Mix-Beimengungsgetränke, die man so üblicherweise nimmt, wie Cola etc., einfach durch Club-Mate ersetzt und so die ganzen Klassiker wie Cuba Libre etc. einfach in Mate-Mix-Getränke umgewandelt. Also der Club hieß ja nicht umsonst auch Club-Forschung, sondern wurde dann halt auch verballt und zu Club-Forschung, denn der Chunk war halt auch einer der... Genau, da kommt der Chunk her. Eine Getränke der Chunk ist Club-Mate mit Rum und gestoßenen Limonen. Ja, und da begann halt so ein bisschen auch meine Wahrnehmung. Parallel dazu und vielleicht eben auch durch diesen Club ausgelöst, das vermag ich jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig zu sagen, gab es das halt auch auf einigen anderen dieser Underground-Clubs. Es gab diese Firma KGB, wo ich mich das erste Mal, glaube ich, auch mit Marte eingedeckt habe, aus dem Rheinland kommt. Wir hatten das ja alles gar nicht, irgendwie so wild. Da war Berlin einfach so weiter. Und außer Franken gab es das dann vielleicht in Berlin und Hamburg noch und vorbei. Und diese KGB-Geschichte Kohlen, Gips und Bier entstanden aus der Hausbesitzer-Szene.
Genau, was man so zum Leben braucht.
Genau, was man so zum Leben braucht. In einem besetzten Haus. Man braucht Kohlen zum Heizen, man braucht Gips zum Renovieren und man braucht Bier zum Party machen bzw. dann halt auch Club-Marte. Dadurch, ich glaube, das war auch dann die Verbindung, wie das dann irgendwie auch auf die Camps... Ja, Martereif ist immer runtergefahren, hat die Marte geholt und KGB hat das dann verteilt. Und über den KGB kam das, glaube ich, auch zum CCC auf das Camp. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe? Ja, also das... Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob, also es gab sicherlich so über Seabase und Clubforschung auch schon, sagen wir mal, direkte Kontakte zur Marte, aber es war dann letztlich der KGB, der eben für diese Beschleunigung gesorgt hat, dass man das eben auch einfach so bestellen konnte. Das war ja vorher so nicht ohne Weiteres möglich, weil man wusste nicht, wo es das gab. Es gab das in keinem Supermarkt nirgendwo, aber man konnte es halt beim KGB bestellen und immer wenn mal wieder Mathe-Reif heimgekehrt war, gab es halt wieder Bestände und die haben sich dann so vor allem eben in der Seabase und im CCC extrem schnell verflüchtigt. Ja, also man muss auch wirklich dazu sagen, ich meine du sitzt hier jetzt als Moderator von Chaos Radio Express, aber du hast durchaus auch eine mate Geschichte und hast ja auch irgendwie auf den Camps oder sowas das angeschleppt. Jaja, ich habe da auch maßgeblich zu beigetragen, dass da die Versorgung immer gestimmt hat. Ich weiß auch noch, es gab mal die Mate-Krise, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau wann das war, aber das muss auch so Anfang 2000 irgendwas gewesen sein. Da gab es aus Gründen, die ich nicht mehr erinnere, gab es einfach mal wochenlang keine Mate mehr. Ich erinnere mich, ja. Und das war wirklich absurd, wie dann auf einmal alle auf dem Zahnfleisch liefen und irgendwie so bis zu acht Euro pro Flasche bezahlt haben, wenn mal irgendwie eine greifbar war. Da hat sich dann irgendwie wirklich ganz deutlich abgezeichnet, wie irre dann doch schon so diese Hingabe war. Also es war halt auch hackergeschichtlich sozusagen eine Zäsur. Vor einiger Zeit habe ich dann auch nochmal mit Steffen Veneri gesprochen über das Thema Mate und er meinte, ja, das ist er. Also es kam ja alles nach unserer Zeit. Also die alten Herren, die den CCC gegründet haben. Also klar, Anfang der 80er in Hamburg im CCC, da wurde nicht Mate getrunken. Das gab es einfach nicht. Und das war dann sicherlich auch so, mit der Mate kam halt auch eine neue Zeit in die Hacker-Szene und in den Chaos Computer Club. Das stimmt. Das ist ja sozusagen das offizielle Getränk einer neuen Generation gewesen. Genau, plötzlich waren die Camps irgendwie ein bisschen größer und internationaler. Plötzlich wurde der Kongress ganz anders.
Also gerade beim Kongress merkt man es halt, wenn es nirgendwo anders mehr Mate gibt, dann ist gerade der Kongress…
Weil die Bestände komplett weggekauft sind.
Definitiv. Dieses Jahr war es nicht so schlimm, weil es gab ja irgendwie noch eine zweite Mate-Sorte und deswegen musste nicht so viel Club-Mate auf Wochen hin von Loschar produziert werden, nur für den Kongress. Aber die letzten Jahre habe ich schon immer gemerkt, dass in Leipzig gab es irgendwie, um Weihnachten waren die Geschäfte leer.
Der Bezug von Club-Mate war auch immer so eine spannende Geschichte. Das muss ich noch hinterfragen. Du meinst ernsthaft, wenn der Kongress stattfindet, dann gibt es sozusagen eine Mate-Krise in anderen Regionen?
Bei meinem Dealer gab es nichts mehr.
Das ist aber bekannt. Mir ist das neu.
Du wohnst in Berlin.
Naja, eben, hier gab es immer.
Da können sie doch fast eine Leitung legen.
Das ist ja wie in der Zone, die ganze Versorgung geht nach Berlin. Und das Land muss leiden.
Man hat das aber immer so ein Ding, wo man ein bisschen Energie reinstecken muss, um sich selbst zu besorgen.
Ja, außer man wohnt halt in Berlin und tritt irgendwie aus der Tür und holt sich das im Späti irgendwie um die Ecke. Hier gibt es das auch in allen Getränke-Großhändlern. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem mehr.
Auf Helgoland musst du es mit dem Schiff kommen lassen.
Völlig dekadent. Naja, auf Helgoland muss man alles mit dem Schiff kommen lassen. Ja, also ich kann mich erinnern, wir haben auch zum Thema Schiff vom Chaos Computer Club in Köln im Jahr 2000 eine Veranstaltung gemacht. Das Hackschiff, das war ja so eine kleine Veranstaltung, wo wir dann irgendwie auf dem Rhein rumgefahren sind. Und alle sind da angekommen und da hieß es dann halt auch, Mensch, also wenn wir die Berliner da hinlocken wollen, dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall Marta am Start haben. Und uns fielen uns halt auch nichts Besseres ein, wo wir dieses Zeug herkriegen könnten, außer aus Berlin. Und das haben wir dann halt auch gemacht. Also sind morgens irgendwie um sechs losgefahren von Köln aus, haben den Wagen mit Marte vollgeladen. Und als wir angekommen sind in Berlin, sind wir sofort wieder zurück. Und das war so eine Tagestour. Aber irgendwann hat sich das dann auch ein bisschen normalisiert. Und wir haben halt auch gedacht, dass es auch Quatsch irgendwie, ja, 800 Kilometer Auto fahren nur, um Marte zu holen. Das muss irgendwie anders gehen. Da muss man auch mal bei Loscher, das ist ja diese Brauerei, die das da macht, muss man auch mal anrufen können und fragen, wie die das liefern. Die waren zu dem Zeitpunkt aber noch nicht so richtig daran interessiert, das wirklich extrem geschäftlich zu betreiben. Ich kann mich da halt noch daran erinnern, dass wir da angerufen haben und gesagt haben, ja, Vertrieb bei Loscher und wen könnte man da da sprechen? Und die Stimme am anderen Ende des Telefons sagte, der Papa ist gerade nicht da. Also es ist halt eine richtige fränkische Familienbrauerei. Man merkt auch bei Loscher, also beim älteren Herrn Loscher, beim Papa Loscher, im Herzen ist der halt Bierbrauer. Also das haben wir gemerkt, als wir dann wirklich dann lückenlose Marteversorgung auch im Rheinland hatten, haben wir gemerkt, jedes Mal will der uns auch noch mal irgendwie sein komisches Weißbier da unterjubeln. Immer mit der Argumentation, er trinkt es aber nicht nur Marte. Aber nein, wir wollten wirklich nur Marte. Ich weiß, dass das Herz von Papa Loscher tatsächlich an der Bierbrauerei hängt, aber ich glaube er ist auch so selber ein bisschen überrascht. Also bei Führungen, die er dann hat in seiner Brauerei, sagt er dann auch immer so, ja, und dann ist das alles irgendwie in Informatiker-Kreisen sehr beliebt, was wir hier machen. Also ganz weiß auch glaube ich die Loscher-KG nicht so richtig, wie sie diesen Erfolg von Marte irgendwie einschätzen soll. Ja, aber es ist doch merkwürdig. Ich meine, es gibt ja mit der ICMP, denn ja sozusagen auch noch in Münchsteinach, quasi wie man so schön sagt, an der Quelle, dann auch immer noch so eine Sommerveranstaltung alle zwei Jahre, immer wenn kein Camp ist. Und das findet ja sozusagen auch dann direkt vor Ort mit Unterstützung auch von LOSHA Stadt. Also so langsam müsste es ihnen ja auch sein, ne? Ja, klar, das wissen sie auch. Also was da so passiert, ist irgendwie auch klar. Aber sie sind halt, glaube ich, weniger daran interessiert als, sagen wir mal, Coca-Cola. Also das ist auch halt ganz klares Programm bei LOSHA. Sie machen kein Sponsoring. Also sie behaupten halt, wenn sie einmal mit anfangen würden, dann müssten sie das überall und so. Haben sie wahrscheinlich Recht? Haben sie vielleicht Recht, aber ich denke, irgendwie wäre auch schon nett, wenn man sich dann halt der Szene mal irgendwie erkenntlich zeigen würde. Aber ja, kein Interesse. Es gibt irgendwie ganz wenig so Merchandising, Artikel. Das ist ja eigentlich so der heimliche Grund, warum wir dieses Hackerbrause-Block eröffnet haben, damit wir irgendwie mit Geschenken zugeschmissen werden.
Ist noch nicht so richtig passiert.
Ist noch nicht so richtig passiert, aber zu ganz lumpen lassen hat sich dann Luscha auch nicht. Also es gibt diese super beliebten aufblasbaren Rucksäcke von Club-Marte. Und es gibt so einen kleinen Martetrack, es gibt Aufkleber und ja, gibt halt auch vor allen Dingen.
Was man halt so hat als Brauerei.
Genau. Stimmt, wir haben ja früher sogar auch unsere eigene Club-Marte-Shirts gemacht. Richtig. Fiel mir da gerade wieder ein. Soweit geht's, dass man sich selber dann Merchandising herstellt, weil der Hersteller irgendwie kein Bock drauf hat. Okay, was ist jetzt eure Theorie? Also, was ist drin in der Club-Marte? Warum dieses Getränk und warum nicht alle anderen Cola-Sorten, die es über die Jahre gab, warum nicht andere Brausen? Warum Club-Marte?
Es ist ein Mem.
Meinst du?
Irgendwo schon, ja.
Es ist auch ein Mem, klar. Also, man redet sich das dann halt auch mal gegenseitig ein und so und so die ganz irren Sachen mit über Kontinente hinweg importieren oder so. Das wäre sicherlich nicht möglich, wenn es kein Mem wäre. Aber ja, schmeckt auch einigermaßen. Also, es ist nicht so pappig süß wie viele Colas und hat zwar Zucker drin, aber halt dann auch nicht so irre viel. Es hat so einen Teegeschmack und enthält dann diese Gerbstoffe, die dafür sorgen, dass das Koffein einen nicht trifft wie ein Faustschlag ins Gesicht, sondern mehr so langsam sich im Körper verteilt.
Das ist halt das Gegenteil von einem Energy-Drink. Beim Energy-Drink sind halt eher Sachen, die deinen Metabolismus halt irgendwie nochmal anheizen, damit irgendwie das Koffein schön transportiert wird. Bei Club Mart ist es mehr, dass du es über einen längeren Zeitraum schön gemütlich aufnimmst und es ist angenehmer.
Also es sickert ein.
Genau. Es erwischt dich nicht wie so eine Wand, sondern genau.
Du läufst so langsam in den Busch. Schönes Bild. Ja, und jetzt gucken wir alle auf unsere Mateflaschen. Ja, weil ich meine, über eins haben wir noch gar nicht geredet, nämlich über Mate. Ich meine, mittlerweile ist es ja schon so, dass wenn man Mate sagt, dass man Club-Mate meint, aber es enthält ja auch unter anderem auch irgendwie noch Mate. Hier steht drin, Mate, Tee, Extrakt. Kommt denn das Koffein in der Club-Mate aus der Mate? Ja, also das ist eine Pflanze, die sehr viel Koffein enthält. Also ich glaube, eine der Pflanzen, die den höchsten Koffein enthält. Das sind ja gar nicht so viele, das sind doch, glaube ich, nur fünf oder so.
Es gibt einige Pflanzen. Cola, Nuss und es gibt eben noch diese Rotholzgewechsel, die teilweise auch Koffein enthalten.
Aber es sind gar nicht so viele. Richtig. Auf jeden Fall schon seit Urzeiten halt in Südamerika beliebt und ich kenne auch relativ viele Leute, die bei Mate nicht unbedingt an Club-Mate denken, sondern sich halt ihre Mate selber machen. Also das ist wohl gerade in Argentinien oder so was, ist das halt so der Standard, dass man sagt, dann treffen wir uns auf ein paar Unas-Maters. Wie kann man das auf Deutsch sagen? Ein paar Maten? Ein paar Matata? Was ist der Plural von Mate? Mate-Getränkeinheiten.
Genau.
Trinken wir ein paar Mate-Getränkeinheiten zusammen?
Tatsächlich hast du ja diesen Quenchua, diesen hohlen Kürbis, wo du es draus hinkst mit so einem Stoheim, der unten irgendwie ein Sieb dran hat. Und normalerweise tust du halt deine Mateblätter in dieses Gefäß rein und gieß es halt immer wieder mit heißem Wasser auf und zuselst da raus. Und das ist unglaublich bitter, das Zeug.
Ja, also, ist das schon mal vor Ort? Ja, klar. Also regelmäßig eigentlich vor Ort. In Südamerika? Das nicht, das nicht.
Aber auf traditionell zubereitete Artenweise kann man das schon mal trinken.
Also was muss man da jetzt konkret machen? Also man braucht diesen Kürbis.
Das ist im Prinzip so ein holergetrockneter Kürbis. Manchmal so ein bisschen auch eingefasst mit irgendwelchem Metall. Und dazu hast du einen, wie heißt dieser Stohalm? Bombilla, oder? Genau. Das ist so ein Stohalm. Und unten ist da so ein kleines Sieb dran, damit du nicht irgendwie die Mate in den Stohalm einatmest, sondern halt irgendwie da einfach nur die Flüssigkeit trinkst.
Also man nimmt die Blätter der Pflanze.
Richtig. Genau.
Und dann? Also kann man entweder, es gibt grüne Mate, es gibt geröstete Mate auch. Jetzt beides. Schmeckt unterschiedlich. Ich mag die geröstete ein bisschen lieber. Und wird dann halt eingefüllt und dann wird heißes Wasser drauf gegossen. Und das ist so dieses typische Bild, was man wohl dann in Südamerika immer wieder sieht. Leute, die halt dieses Kürbisgefäß bei sich haben, diesen Strohhalm und immer eine Thermoskanne mit heißem Wasser. Und da wird dann halt die ganze Zeit heißes Wasser nachgegossen. Und kann man den ganzen Tag halt irgendwie so ein bisschen rumnuckeln an diesem Koffein-Trink. Und das macht dann sozusagen, gibt dann einfach so diese permanente, das ist so diese Feindosierung von Koffein. Und durch diese Gerbstoffe ist sozusagen auch gesichert gestellt, dass das sich im Körper auch entsprechend langsam entfaltet. Das ist dann sozusagen auch das Äquivalent zu diesen Coca-Blätter kauen, wo man auch so ein bisschen durch diese permanenten Speicheldurchwalkungen des Blattes eben immer so Minimalstmengen von dem Coca austreibt und dann sozusagen in kleinen Dosen in den Körper reingeht. Also wird dann, was weiß ich, in Argentinien auch häufig mit dieser Gaucho-Kultur in Verbindung gebracht, also den argentinischen Cowboys, die halt die ganze Zeit da auf die Rinder aufpassen müssen und ähnlich wie Fernfahrer, die halt irgendwie neben den Hackern wahrscheinlich so die großen Koffein-Genießer sind, sind das dann halt... Ach, die Hacker sind ja sozusagen die Gauchos des 21.
Die Hacker sind die Fernfahrer des Internets.
Also Koffein ist, muss man vielleicht dazu auch sagen, nicht für alle Sachen wirklich super geeignet. Also kreativer wird man halt nicht durch Koffein unbedingt, sondern man bleibt letztendlich nur wach und für viele Sachen, für viele Tätigkeiten ist das genau das, was erwünscht ist. Aber also wenn man halt zum Beispiel Fernfahrer ist oder Cowboy oder sowas und einfach wach bleiben muss, dann ist halt so eine permanente Koffeinzufuhr genau das Richtige. Für diese nächtlichen Hack-Sessions im Grunde macht man sich da selber was vor. Also wenn das Gehirn einfach müde ist, dann kann man sich zwar aufputschen, aber es arbeitet dann einfach nicht kreativer und kann halt irgendwie ja noch mehr. Aber ich glaube, das hat doch keiner behauptet, oder? Dass jetzt Club-Marte der Kreativ-Input ist. Es haut nicht so ganz hin mit dem, was man vielleicht erst programmieren oder so dann nachts übermacht, wo man dann halt irgendwie wirklich einen klaren Kopf braucht oder irgendwie Gedanken, Geistesblitze braucht oder so was. Man bleibt einfach nur wach letztendlich. Und ja, so gern ich halt irgendwie koffeinhaltige Getränke mag, schlafen ist halt irgendwie durch nicht zu ersetzen.
Es verhindert im Prinzip nur, dass du einschläfst und nicht, gibt dir keine neuen Impulse oder so.
Sonst noch was tolles drin in der Club-Mate?
Nö.
Also, hier steht Aroma, Koffein drauf.
Dann werden die vielleicht einfach irgendwelches Koffein aus entkoffiniertem Kaffee da irgendwie noch dazu reinkippen. Kann gut sein. Also, das Koffein, was normalerweise in Getränken verwendet wird, das stammt zum größten Teil aus entkoffiniertem Kaffee. Abfallprodukt quasi, ja. Das wird dann in irgendwelche Kopfschmerztabletten und in irgendwelche Getränke hauptsächlich reingemischt.
Jetzt hat ja die Club-Marte dann eben den von uns schon so angedeuteten Siegeszug angetreten, wie auch immer, dass sich dann, ja, also wenn ich wüsste, was da eigentlich letzten Endes schuld war, aber ich denke, die Computerkultur hat zumindest ihren Teil dazu beigetragen, auch wenn es nicht das einzige war, was es so popularisiert hat. Ich kann ja auch nicht davon sprechen, dass es jetzt schon im Mainstream angekommen wäre, aber es gibt zumindest, denke ich mal, so in dieser Computersubkultur, ist es einfach mal bekannt wie ein bunter Hund.
Ganz im Gegenteil, gerade im Mainstream ist ja Club-Marte eher irgendwelchen normalen Menschen eine Club-Marte in die Hand zu drücken, da ist die erste Reaktion, wie schmeckt denn das? Das ist ja eklig. Und ich meine, Loscher hat ja quasi versucht, dem entgegenzuwirken mit irgendeiner Eisteesorte, Club-Marte für Leute, die keine Club-Marte mögen.
Na, der Spruch von, also bei dem einzigen ernsthaften Versuch von Loscher, dann Werbung zu machen, hatten sie sich dann auch einen Slogan ausgedacht. Man gewöhnt sich daran und das ist es halt einfach. Wie sagt man auf Englisch, acquired taste, genau wie es irgendwie schreckliche Käsesorten und Weinsorten gibt, die man halt irgendwie wirklich mal erlernen muss, zu schmecken, muss man halt auch irgendwie die Mate erlernen, zu schmecken.
Also mit Mater grenzt man sich schon ganz schön ab. Und ich glaube, das ist vielleicht, kommt vielleicht auch so in einer Nerdkultur so ein bisschen entgegen, dass man der mit der Mate ist, der jetzt das Getränk hat, was andere Leute überhaupt nicht mögen. Und vielleicht ist das auch so ein kulturelles Ding.
Kann auf jeden Fall sein. Also ich hab, ja klar, dann gibt's dann diese Zusammenkünfte, was weiß ich, Kongress oder Camp oder sowas. Und dann werden halt immer wieder Leute neu angefixt. Vielleicht ist das halt dann auch Teil dieses Memes, wenn man es dann über sich gebracht hat, wirklich die ersten zwei Flaschen, ohne Gesicht zu verziehen, zu trinken, dann möchte man halt auch gerne da bleiben bleiben. Vor vier Jahren war ja das bisher letzte, also dritte und bisher letzte Camp mit großer internationaler Beteiligung. Und da gab es ja ohnehin ganz Menge Fernwirkungen. Hatte man so den Eindruck, dass auf einmal die deutsche Hackerkultur in einem Maße inspirierend gewirkt hat, wie schon lange nicht mehr. So hatten das ja hier auch bei CRE schon ein paar Mal mit der Diskussion um die Hacker-Spaces, was auch so ein bisschen, also nicht unbedingt seinen Anfang gefunden hat, aber zumindest sein Revival da ausgelöst wurde. Das ist relativ klar nachzuvollziehen. Aber die Club-Marte hat ja sozusagen dann auch den Weg gefunden. Was ist denn da eigentlich passiert? Also das war, das war glaube ich sicherlich so eine Sache, die diese amerikanischen Austausch-Hacker, Au-pair-Hacker, Forschungsreisenden in Sachen Hackerspace oder so auf jeden Fall mitgenommen haben bei diesem Camp. Nach dem Motto, du willst eine funktionierende Hacker-Community haben, dann brauchst du einen Hackerspace und dann brauchst du Club-Marte. Weil das ist das, was wir da gesehen haben sozusagen. Das war so die Handlungsreisenden, kehrten aus China zurück und haben festgestellt, so funktioniert das. Ja, es ist erstaunlich schwierig da. Also ich hatte gedacht, Mensch, zumindest ist es irgendwie der gleiche Kontinent Amerika, wenn auch nicht Südamerika. Da muss doch irgendwas Mate ähnliches aufzutreiben sein. Es gibt so ein bisschen was. Es gibt Zoll-Mate, glaube ich aus Zoll-Mate. Zoll, wie die Sonne. Das ist glaube ich in Kalifornien, dann gibt es eine obskure Mate-Sorte aus Miami und so. Aber irgendwas, was vergleichbar wäre mit der Club-Mate, also halt so eine Limonade mit Mate-Geschmack, gibt es halt wirklich irgendwie gar nicht. Und da gab es die absurdesten Versuche, dann halt das Ganze zu reverse-ingenieren. Es gibt vom O'Reilly-Verlag diese Zeitschrift Make, wo diese Selbermacher-Kultur und Elektronik-Basteln und was weiß ich alles angefallen wird. Und da war natürlich auch dann, ja, ziemlich direkt nach dem Camp ein Rezept drin, wie man denn selber Mate brauen kann. Also, wie man sich seine kohlensäurehaltige Frischungs-Mate brauen kann. Sie haben es auch tatsächlich Club-Mate genannt und haben gesagt, das sei ein Rezept für Club-Mate. Würde anders schmecken, weil die Club-Mate in Deutschland, die hätte ja Mate-Sirup-Extrakt und so weiter. Und hier würde es man mit frischen Mate-Blättern und frischen Mate-Tee, deswegen sei das alles irgendwie geschmacklich ein bisschen anders. Naja. Kennst du jemand, der das mal gemacht hat? Ich kenne Leute, die das gemacht haben, aber es ist wirklich nicht vergleichbar. Also es gibt ja auch in Deutschland irgendwie Mate-Getränke, die ein bisschen Martiger schmecken. Also diese Lid-Mate schmeckt einfach ein bisschen mehr nach Tee. Und finde ich auch okay. Also vor allen Dingen, wenn es gekühlt ist, kann man das irgendwie ganz gut trinken. Aber diese selbst gebrauten Versuche mit Marte-Tee kochen, Zucker und Kohlensäure dazu, das hat mich irgendwie, also immer wenn ich es probiert habe, fand ich total schrecklich. Das ist so ein bisschen Alchemie. Das wahre Gold kommt man nur in Münchstein nach.
Na, es gibt so eine DIY-selbstgemachte Mate aus Dresden, die Zick-Zack-Mate. Die hatten wir auch schon mal auf dem Gender-Camp verkostet und die finde ich persönlich ziemlich lecker. Die schmeckt ein bisschen leicht süßlicher, ein bisschen zitronig, aber die ist echt super trinkbar. Ist aber leider kein Ding, das man so offiziell im Laden kaufen kann, sondern das macht wohl auch irgendjemand so in der Badewanne oder so.
Zick-Zack-Mate ist auf jeden Fall empfehlenswert. Genau.
Du musst jemanden kennen, der die Nummer vom Bruder, von dem hat, der die macht. Nein, wirklich.
Das ist ja wie zu Zeiten der Prohibition.
Er ist im Osten. Da gibt es Sachen nur unter der Ladentheke, die guten.
Ja, so war es dann halt auch, glaube ich, auch für die Amerikaner, die das dann irgendwie versucht haben zu importieren.
Die haben es noch nicht hingekriegt, das ordentlich selbst zu machen.
Genau. Die Idee war halt schon irgendwie, was weiß ich, dann importiert man sich halt irgendwie den Lemonadengrundstoff und mixt das dann irgendwie da zusammen. Aber selbst das hat halt nicht funktioniert und es endete dann... Weil es den so nicht gibt beim Loscher. Nicht mit Loscher nehmen. Und ja, das endete dann wirklich damit, dass die da einfach Schiffsladungen mit Mate im New Yorker Hafen gelöscht haben. Da hat sich dann 2600, also diese amerikanische Hacker-Zeitschrift, Unternehmung oder sowas von, ja, hauptsächlich Eric Corley, also Emmanuel Goldstein, sehr darum bemüht gemacht. Also die haben tatsächlich dann auch das als neuen Geschäftszweig von 2600 Industries dann angemeldet, den Import von Mate.
Ich kann mich erinnern, als die erste Fuse Mate alle war, dann wurde für die letzte Flasche Mate, ich glaube im NYC Resistor, so ein Schrein gebaut. Und die durfte keiner leer trinken, weil wenn im Hacker-Space die Mate alle ist, dann ist das ja eine ganz furchtbare Situation.
Das Ende der Welt ist sozusagen da, das Eschaton ist dann immer identisiert.
Definitiv, da dürfte die nicht angefasst werden, bis nicht die nächste Lieferung wieder da ist.
Da ließen sie sich auch wirklich nicht von abbringen. Also es gibt halt auch, es gab dann irgendwie Sachen, wie gesagt wurde, ja Mensch, hier irgendwie teure europäische Getränke übers Meer schippern lassen und so. Das muss da nun wirklich nicht sein. Wir haben noch, was weiß ich, es gibt dieses, ich glaube Manhattan Special, das ist so eine, auch ganz lecker, so eine Espresso-Lemo, die sie in New York haben, auch von so einer kleinen Brauerei. Aber nee, das war es dann alles nicht. Also man wollte schon das trinken, was die richtigen Hacker in Europa auch trinken. Ja, sonst kommt man nicht in den Hackerhimmel. So, und dann haben sie sich also palettenweise das Zeug kommen lassen, ging das dann irgendwie auch gut weg? Also es ging gut weg. Also es gab halt noch irgendwie einige richtig große Schwierigkeiten, weil man muss dann halt, wenn man in Amerika was verkauft, muss man hinten so einen Zettel drauf haben, wo Nutrition-Facts draufstehen und so. Da musste das dann halt auch alles übersetzt werden und extra Etiketten geklebt werden, nur für den amerikanischen Markt und so weiter. Loscher war da wohl auch ein bisschen überfordert, aber mit Zusammenarbeit, ich glaube, am Schluss waren da noch irgendwelche Schweizer beteiligt, die diese Übersetzung dann auch noch mitgemacht haben und mit Loscher konferiert haben. Es war halt auch schwierig, weil die Jungs von 26th Hundred alle nicht irgendwie ausreichend Deutsch sprachen und Loscher irgendwie kein Interesse hatte, da seine Geschäftsverhandlungen auf Englisch zu führen. Und am Schluss haben sie es geschafft und haben dann halt regelmäßig dann auch Mate in die USA gebracht. In die Neuwelt.
Mittlerweile gibt es sogar englischsprachige Originaletiketten.
Genau. Und in welche Beträge müssen dann bezahlt werden vor Ort, um so eine Mate dann zu erwerben? Ich glaube, so der Standardpreis für eine Flasche ist 5 Dollar. Aber es ist halt die gute aus Deutschland.
Definitiv. Also Club-Mate ist auch sehr beliebt überall. Ich kenne auch Leute, die importieren das nach Norwegen. Dort darf es nicht offiziell verkauft werden, weil der Koffeingehalt nicht den norwegischen Nahrungsmittel-Richtlinien entspricht. Man darf da quasi immer nur so eine Eigenverbrauchsmenge über die Grenze mitnehmen.
Was ist denn daran falsch, dass es in Norwegen da nicht den Bestimmungen entspricht?
Na, es ist so viel Koffein drin. Also Norwegen hat da ein bisschen stängere Gesetze als Deutschland.
Du hast so 25 Milligramm.
Genau, das ist das, was in Deutschland erlaubt ist. In Norwegen sind es glaube ich, ich weiß es nicht auswendig. Ich habe versucht, das rauszufinden, aber die Feniger und Club-Marte im Geschäft ginge halt nicht.
Und den Trick, mit dem was in einem EU-Land erlaubt ist, geht halt auch nicht in Norwegen, weil Norwegen halt nicht in der EU ist. Genau.
Und deswegen gibt es halt dann nur Leute, die quasi jedes Mal, wenn sie in Deutschland ihren Kofferraum vollmachen. Ich glaube so sechs Kisten sind irgendwie okay und das ist dann das, wovon dort der Hacker-Space dann einfach zehren muss bis zur nächsten Lieferung und ist ja eigentlich kein Zustand, aber...
Wie heißt der Hacker-Space da in Oslo?
Oslo oder Bergen? Ich bin mir grad auch nicht mehr so sicher.
Es gibt eine Initiative in Bergen, Hackbergen, aber ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Es gibt auf jeden Fall in Oslo ein funktionierender Hacker-Space.
Aber... Der ist da in so einem Kulturzentrum.
Das heißt, wenn sowieso mal jemand vorhat, da nach Oslo zu fahren und Lust hat da mit Hackern zusammenzukommen, dann kann er erstens da Leute finden und wenn er sozusagen den Kofferraum voll am Mate hat, dann ist er auch gleich...
Da macht er sich Freunde.
Früher hat man sich im Skandinavien-Urlaub Freunde gemacht, wenn man Alkohol brachte.
Heute fährt man auf einen Martedampfer. Aus der Mate-Ebene.
Was ist denn diese anderen... Also im Hackerbrause-Block habt ihr ja nun eigentlich so alles mögliche getestet, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Wann auch immer ein Erfrischungsgetränk mit Koffein daherkommt, muss das auch Kohlensäure enthalten? Das war, glaube ich, der zweite oder dritte Artikel oder so, wo wir dann auch mal was über Kaffee geschrieben haben oder so. Wir sind da relativ offen. Es steht auch immer noch der große Artikel zum Kochen und Backen mit Mate an.
Es fehlt auch noch das Review über Club-Mate. Das haben wir nämlich aufgehoben, weil wir da einen Special-Gest versuchen anzuleiern. Ansonsten, ich glaube, wir haben mit dem Blog, das Problem ist, da kommt nicht viel Neues nach. Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass wir einfach den Markt, dessen, was es hier so an Getränken gibt, schon ziemlich abgegrast haben. Also diese ganzen hoch-Coffeinhaltigen Cola-Sorten, die sind alle verblockt. Wenn sich da was tut, wir haben uns übelst gefreut, als es Lied-Mate gab, weil wir dann endlich quasi wieder was Neues hatten. Wir sind auch immer wieder dankbar, wenn uns Leute irgendwie auf Sachen stupsen oder hinweisen oder uns in zweifel auch Sachen schicken.
Aber man kann so ein bisschen mal durchgehen, was wir so in den letzten Jahren alles besprochen haben. Das war natürlich irgendwie Red Bull Cola.
Oh ja, da gab es auch diesen schönen Skandal mit, das ist ja alles mit Kokain und das geht ja gar nicht und das muss jetzt alles verboten werden.
Da hatte jetzt diese wunderbare Formulierung im Blog, also es gab Kokainspuren in der Red Bull Cola und deswegen gab es in Deutschland eine große Rückrufaktion und jetzt schrieb dann, Kokain, die Kinderpornografie der Lebensmittelbranche. Ja, ich meine, es kommt mit besten Familien vor. Gab es nicht auch Kokainspuren auf der Bundestagstoilette? War da nicht mal sowas?
Ja, auf jedem Geldstand ist mehr als in Red Bull Cola. Also das war tatsächlich eine ziemlich hanebüchende Sache.
Das war wahrscheinlich eher so eine Marketing-Aktion von irgendjemand, oder?
Na, man weiß es nicht. Sie haben halt einfach, dass da irgendwie Rotholz gewichst drin ist im Geschmack. Das ist eigentlich bei allen Colasorten so. Sie haben es halt einfach nochmal exakt aufgeführt als Coca-Blätter, um eben ihren Anspruch, da sind nur natürliche Sachen zu untermauern. Und dann hat irgendjemand da gesagt, was, Coca-Blätter? Und dann wurde das irgendwie analysiert. Und im Endeffekt ist die Menge, die da drin war, man hätte irgendwie diverse LKW-Ladungen davon trinken müssen, um irgendwie in einen Rauschzustand zu gelangen.
Also ziemlich nett. Also vom Geschmack her finde ich eigentlich diese Cola Rebell, die wir auch ziemlich früher hatten.
Stimmt. Aus Hamburg natürlich.
Natürlich. Mit Chili-Geschmack.
Ja. Gibt es in drei Stärken. Es gibt so eine, die ein bisschen nach Chili schmeckt, eine, die ein bisschen mehr nach Chili schmeckt und eine, eine Chili, die ein bisschen nach Cola schmeckt. Also sehr, sehr zu empfehlen. Sollte man es sich echt mal geben so.
Hab es da nicht irgendwie dieses, was ist mit diesem Feststoff?
Ja, die gibt es auch zum Blutschen.
Genau. Gibt es auch als Feststoff-Cola. Feststoff-Cola? Als Lolli oder was?
Bom-Bombs. Ach so. Du hast dann quasi so eine Packung Bom-Bombs und dann nimmst du eins und dann siehst du, wie wenn du so eine halbe Flasche Cola dinkst. Also das ist ganz okay.
Begeistert heute ist auch irgendwie, glaube ich, Skull.
Skull.
Was aber wirklich, ja, also das ist glaube ich eher... Skull wie Totenkopf oder was?
Genau.
Das ist eher was für, ja, Fortgeschrittene.
Für Fortgeschrittene. Ja, das ist quasi, wenn du den Club-Mate-Effekt nochmal in ganz krasse erleben wollt, mal Skull probieren. Das ist quasi so diesen Effekt. Es schmeckt erstmal nicht. Den hat man bei Skull einfach nochmal ein bisschen verstärkt.
Aber das ist jetzt wieder ein Getränk, ein Lutschbombon.
Das ist ein Getränk.
Das ist aus Schwarztee und ist in einer dermaßenen Konzentration, dass einem halt wirklich beim ersten Schluck immer die Gesichtszüge entgleisen. Also es geht gar nicht in das. Es ist wirklich extrem. Das Skull-Gesicht. Das Skull-Gesicht gibt es auch irgendwie, glaube ich.
Warum?
Weil das so bitter ist oder was? Das ist echt schon sehr bitterteeig und nicht so wie ein netter Tee, der man sich aufgebrüht hat, sondern konzentriert.
Also es gibt dann noch die rote Version, die ist irgendwie ein ganz normaler Limo im Prinzip, aber die schwarze Version, die ist richtig klasse.
Genau, mit Schwarztee und Guarana.
Deren Claim ist auch, süß sind die anderen.
Das heißt, da ist gar kein Zucker drin oder was? So weit, dass man das bitter überlebt.
Genau. Also das darf man durchaus mal probieren. Vielleicht wird es ja der nächste heiße Scheiß.
Aber das sind schon so jetzt, wir reden jetzt schon von so Marken, die auch in irgendeiner Form im Vertrieb sind. Ja, das ist in irgendeiner Form im Vertrieb, in der Tat. Man kann sich das sogar, ich glaube sogar, im Internet bestellen und kriegt dann irgendwie so eine Packung sogar nach Hause geliefert. Und es gibt es auch ab und zu in irgendwelchen Kneipen hier in Berlin.
Das gibt es ja auch in irgendwelchen Spätis, habe ich es auch schon gesehen. Also Berlin ist ja das zweite Macker für Hackerbrausen und das ist ein Berliner.
Vielleicht ist es einfach so, vielleicht wird das einfach alles in Hamburg produziert und in Berlin.
Sky kommt aus Berlin, das weiß ich. Das gibt es auch hier, das habe ich in Hamburg auch noch nie gesehen.
Wir sind immer interessiert aus anderen Ländern. Asien ist irgendwie echt viel zu wenig abgedeckt. Wir haben Bacchus-D aus Korea. Das ist halt aber ein normaler Energy-Drink.
Ist das nicht so, dass das quasi die Grundformel von Red Bull ist?
Red Bull-ähnliche Getränke gibt es irgendwie unheimlich viele in Asien, in Thailand, in Japan. Gummibärchen mit Koffein sozusagen.
Gummibärchen-Getränke gibt es halt auch hier unglaublich viel. Das ist auch so ein Bereich, den wir nicht wirklich abdecken, außer da gibt es jetzt irgendwie etwas besonders Außergewöhnliches oder besonders Spannendes. Weil so den ex-beliebigen neuen Energy-Drink, der einfach nur nach Gummibärchen und Zucker mit Koffein schmeckt, den braucht man nicht irgendwie bewerten oder braucht man nicht irgendwie promoten. Also wir sind halt eher interessiert an so Cola-Mate-EE.
Ja, aber es gibt auch noch andere Mate-Artikel, also Lid-Mate habt ihr jetzt schon erwähnt. Es gibt auch Flora-Power. Ja, Flora-Power, genau. Lid-Mate ist basierend auf Flora-Power. Also wenn man Flora-Power kennt, dann erkennt man auch schnell wieder, aha, da ist nur eigentlich ein anderes Etikett drauf.
Es ist quasi ein Fork. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass also die erste Version, also das Lustige an Lid-Mate ist, das wird ja, wie es bei Neues üblich ist, versioniert. Und die 01er-Version, das war tatsächlich irgendwie Flora-Mate einfach umgewebelt. Die 02er-Version ist halt mit bisschen mehr Koffein und ein bisschen mehr Kohlen-Säure und mal gucken. Und bei Lid-Mate, das ist ja so Rezept-mäßig, soll das drauf hinauslaufen, dass es was wirklich Eigenständiges wird und dass im Endeffekt auch dieses Rezept Open Source ist und dass jeder quasi das Rezept einsehen kann und wenn da die Techniker sich das auch selbst zusammen basteln kann.
Und 02 ist die aktuelle Version?
Meines Wissens nach. Ich weiß nicht, ob die mittlerweile ein Update haben, aber...
Ach, die arbeiten da ständig dran. Also es ist halt auch, ja, mit diesem Premium-Betriebssystem, was wir da eingangs schon erwähnt haben oder so, soll sich das ja alles irgendwie dann nochmal Open Source-mäßig weiterentwickeln. Also das heißt, das Rezept ist auch sozusagen bekannt?
Noch nicht, weil sie halt noch irgendwie Flora-Mate als Grundsubstanz nehmen und...
Wie können sie denn das tun?
Die haben da irgendwie ein Abkommen mit Flora-Mate.
Ach, das haben sie einfach gekauft.
Aber was das Tolle ist irgendwie, dass man tatsächlich an diesem Getränk sich auch noch proaktiv beteiligen kann. Also ich hab zum Beispiel in meinem ersten Review im Hackerbrausen-Blog den Leuten gesagt, okay, da fehlt einfach Kohlen-Säure, macht mir mehr rein und das ist passiert dann in der nächsten Version. Also wenn es irgendwelche Kritik gibt an dem Getränk oder irgendwelche tollen Ideen, dann kann man den Leuten das einfach mitteilen und dann fließt es auf jeden Fall irgendwo in den Prozess mit ein.
Und die freuen sich sozusagen auch.
Ja, definitiv.
Ach, die sind sehr dahinter her. Ich glaube, ja, also in der Piratenpartei haben sie jetzt glaube ich auch sehr viele Freunde gefunden, die halt sagen, ja, wir trinken nicht mehr Club-Mate, wir trinken nichts. Weil es ist ja Closed Source sozusagen.
Club-Mate war ja auch mal böse.
Club-Mate war kurze Zeit auch mal böse. Da haben wir alle irgendwie überlegt, Mensch, was machen wir denn mit Club-Mate? Da war doch so ein Blogging-Inzident, oder?
Genau.
Was war das nochmal?
Es gab in Berlin Leute, die es lustig fanden, irgendwie ein Plakat zu machen, was sich so an das Club-Mate-Design anlehnt und das ganze Club-Molli zu nennen. Ach die, ja. Genau. Und dann hat irgendwelche Bloggers...
So ein Plakat, was im Wesentlichen zum Aufruf zur...
Genau...
.dem man auch einen Aufruf zur Straßengewalt hätte entnehmen können. Genau. Da war dieser Mate-Mann, der auf den Club-Mate-Flaschen war, mit so einem Molli abgebildet und so. Da kann man sich wirklich über Geschmack streiten. Ich kann auch verstehen, dass da Loscher nicht in die Luft springt und sagt, hurra, so möchten wir gerne vertreten sein. Was allerdings ein bisschen komisch war, dieses Plakat gab es dann halt im Straßenbild. Und irgendjemand hat das fotografiert. Und geblockt. Und geblockt. Und dann kam irgendwie eine Anwaltskanzlei.
Genau, das war nicht Loscher selbst.
Genau, obwohl dieser Blogger das nicht mal in Ansätzen selber hergestellt hätte, sondern einfach nur dokumentiert hat, sollte das dann halt nicht so sein. Das würde irgendwie der Marke Clubmate schaden. Und das dürfte irgendwie so im Internet nicht sein.
Genau, diese Anwälte haben das für eine gute Idee gehalten, diesem Blogger irgendwie einen Brief zu schicken. Ob es jetzt eine Abmahnung war, weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Ja, es war so eine Abmahnung irgendwie. Man kann es ja mal versuchen. Und es ist halt das passiert, was dann bei so was passieren muss. Also es ging halt ein Shitstorm los. Ja, Straßedeffekt. Genau. Wir hatten aber relativ zu viele Zugriffe bei unserem Hacker-Brose-Blog, als sich dann halt die Taz, die Tageszeitung irgendwie noch reingehängt hat in die Berichterstattung und so. Und das war dann, glaube ich, eine Sache von ein, zwei Tagen oder so?
Ja, also es war quasi parallel zum Gender-Camp hat das stattgefunden. Und wir waren sowieso irgendwie auch personell auf einem Haufen und konnten da quasi das ganze Live mitverfolgen. Ich glaube, wir haben dann auch noch angedroht, irgendwie die Sorte zu wechseln, so spaßeshalber. Und dann ist Loscha...
Für mich eine absurde Drohung.
Ja, natürlich. Und Loscha ist dann aber auch ganz schnell zurückgerudert.
Loscha hat gesagt, so war es nicht abgemacht. Mit den Anwälten war es nicht abgemacht. Die haben ja sozusagen ein bisschen Eigendynamik entwickelt.
Anwälte, Gondel, Anwält.
Also sind sie jetzt doch wieder die Guten. Aber sie sind trotzdem closed source. Und die Lead-Mate ist open source. Das ist so ein bisschen so Apple und Android. So noch der Motto.
Für die Leute, die Android auf ihrem Handy haben, die können dann auch Lead-Mate trinken.
Na ich halte an Apple, ich bleib erstmal bei Club-Mate. Ja, dann gab es von Club-Mate auch mal so eine Winter-Edition.
Die gibt es immer noch.
Die gibt es jeden Winter, oder?
Ja, das ist im Prinzip Club-Mate. Und wir hauen da noch so rein, was wir bei Oma im Gewürzschank finden. Und da gibt es sehr geteilte Meinungen. Ich persönlich finde die eigentlich ganz lecker.
Ich finde die auch lecker.
Ich denke, die mögen das nicht. Und irgendwann gab es sogar mal eine Charge, die falsch etikettiert war, wo Leute normale Club-Mate meinten zu kaufen. Und dann war Winter-Mate drin.
Also mit Zimt, Anis, Kardamom, also alles, was man so aus der Weihnachtsbäckerei kennt, ist da immer drin.
Man kann auch Glühwein damit machen oder irgendwie ganz tolle Wintergetränke.
Also da gibt es eigentlich so als den Literaturhinweis in der Richtung von Entropia, also den Leuten vom CCC in Karlsruhe. Die haben in ihrem Wiki also wirklich weder Kosten noch Mühen noch Geschmacksgnosten geschont und haben die ultimative Zusammenstellung zum Thema kochen und backen und überhaupt Getränke herstellen mit Club-Marte gemacht. Also klar, es gibt Fanta-Kuchen, man kann auch Super-Fanta-Kuchen.
Man kann auch Jolt-Pancakes machen, also es geht alles auch mit Club-Marte, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Einfach so in den Teig rein, damit es ein bisschen luftiger wird.
Genau. Man kann sich Kaffee mit Mate machen.
Habt ihr das mal gemacht? Club-Marte-Kuchen habe ich tatsächlich mal gebacken. Was ist dann so die Kuchen-Basis eigentlich? Also was wäre es ohne Club-Marte? Also es gibt einfach, wenn man im Internet nach Fanta-Kuchen googelt, dann findet man relativ viele Rezepte. Und ist auch so ein beliebtes Kindergeburtstagskuchen-Ding. Das war tatsächlich auch der erste Kuchen, den ich gebacken habe. Und kann man natürlich auch mit Club-Marte machen, klar. Aber Kaffee mit Mate ist wohl eher ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftiger.
Du schüttest halt einfach kein Wasser in die Kaffeemaschine, sondern Mate. Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, ich habe es mir nicht gezauert.
Nicht so eine gute Idee, ist wohl auch irgendwie der Feldsalat. Funktioniert das mit der Kohlensäure dann irgendwie? Geht da nicht irgendwie was?
Die geht einfach dabei raus. Ich meine, das wird ja alles irgendwie so hochgekocht und quasi auf hohe Temperaturen erhitzt und die Kohlensäure, das ist da kein Problem.
Schmeckt aber nicht so richtig lecker. Ebenso wie halt der Feldsalat mit frischem Club-Mate-Dressing. Also muss nicht. Aber der Kuchen war gut. Den Kuchen fand ich okay, ja. Mate-Kuchen. Sozusagen so für den Kindergeburtstag für so Kinder im höheren Alter. Genau. Also für Junghacker. Ja, wobei also Loscher, ja, da weiß ich ja nicht so richtig, was ich davon halten soll, aber auch schon sagt irgendwie, ab acht Jahren können Kinder dann auch schon so ein bis zwei Flaschen Club-Mate pro Tag trinken. Weiß ich nicht. Meint ihr ja jetzt sozusagen die Kinderform, also die sozusagen die großen Kinder, die Kinder geblieben sind. Oh ja, ich sehe hier gerade Fanta-Kuchen.
Jedenfalls zu Entropia kann man sagen, es gibt, glaube ich, ziemlich wenig Sachen, die sie sich nicht mit Mate machen würden. Die probieren einfach alles aus. Ich glaube, die sind auch froh, wenn man ihnen irgendwelche tollen Ideen schickt.
Ja, was ich halt nicht schickte, das ist halt auch, glaube ich, eine südwestdeutsche Geschichte, dass man Cola mit Rotwein trinkt. Und das nennt sich dann Korea und da gibt es bei denen North Korea. Das ist dann halt... Und das ist dann Club-Mate mit Rotwein. Also ich hab so manches ausprobiert, aber das ist mir jetzt noch nicht untergekommen. Was ich ja super finde, ist ja dieses Mate Cassis, oder auch diese Kir-Royale-Variante. Also Club-Mate anstatt von Sekt mit Cassis in sehr geringer Dosierung. Ist einfach ein ganz fantastisches, nettes, entspanntes Getränk. Ja oder auch Club-Mate einfach mit Sekt. Also heißt irgendwie Turbo-Mate zum Teil. Es gibt ja, was weiß ich nicht, also Club-Mate mit Wodka, kenn ich auch als Matoka, aber gibt's glaube ich auch andere Namen für. Und natürlich der Chunk rum.
Der Chunk ist ja der Klassiker. Aber Mate-Cocktails ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ja, also bietet sich halt auch an. Also ist ein bisschen tückisch, weil macht halt gleichzeitig wach und betrunken. Und die Blätter hier gerade. Also Glüh-Mate ist dann sozusagen, das ist dann quasi Glühwein-Mate. Ja, also heiße Mate.
Entweder heiße Winter-Mate oder du bastelst selbst was mit irgendwie lustigen Gewürzen.
Es gibt auch noch rote links. Es gibt Mafé, Mate Macchiato und Matfelsaft. Aber Mate Macchiato steht hier nichts zu. Ja, aber glaube ich auch selbst erklärend. Ich weiß nicht, Mate mit Milch oder was? Ja, so was haben wir schon mit Milch schon gemacht.
Allein die Namen sollte man sich durchlesen. Ich denke, du verlinkst das noch in den Show-Notes. Ja, und Muffin.
Tomate. Was ist das? Das steht hier, Tofu mit Mate angebraten. Aber Muckle Pudding mit Mate anstatt Wasser ist ja auch schon mal interessant.
Unsinnliche Möglichkeiten.
Ja, man kann es also wirklich bis zum Exzess treiben. Oh man, super. Ich wusste, dass da was steht, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch nie so tief reingeschaut.
Das ist auch typische Hacker-Kultur einfach. Du nimmst diese Grundsubstanz und denkst dir, was kannst du jetzt damit machen? Und dann probierst du einfach alles aus und die Sachen, die cool sind, die bleiben dann irgendwann mal. Das finde ich großartig.
So, das heißt also, haben wir denn jetzt noch eigentlich außer der Club-Mate und den genannten Mate-Varianten, also gibt es denn noch andere Projekte, die sich jetzt explizit dieser Mate-Limonaden-Kultur noch verschrieben haben oder haben wir da eigentlich jetzt schon alle zusammen?
Ich glaube, wir haben alles mal erwähnt, was es hier so gibt und was wir kennen.
Also ja, also hat man, glaube ich, auch gemerkt, dass wir irgendwie dann doch eher traditionell sind. Aber Elite-Mate sollte man auf jeden Fall im Auge behalten, so ist ja mal ganz gut, dass es noch was gibt. Und wenn man jetzt so viel getrunken hat, wie ihr das so gemacht habt, was fehlt? Also, ich meine, geht das noch weiter? Ist das jetzt irgendwie so ein Ausriss oder gibt es da einfach noch, habt ihr das Gefühl, dass da noch genug Bandbreite für Experimente ist, um wirklich auch noch mal eine Formel zu finden, die, weiß ich nicht, dieses Wachsein, Gutschmecken, irgendwie Besondersein, etc., noch mal irgendwie auf so einen Punkt bringen könnte, wo man bisher noch nicht hingekommen ist?
Das lässt sich, glaube ich, ganz schwer sagen. Es gibt einfach eine unglaubliche Menge an verschiedenen Sachen und auch ganz, ganz viele kleine und unbekannte Sachen, aber im Prinzip kristallisieren sich schon so die Klassiker eben raus. Also es gibt klar Club-Math ist quasi so ein Eins-eins der Teile, die bei jedem im Schank stehen. Dann gibt es ein paar Cola-Sorten überall hin und ob es jetzt da noch das Potenzial gibt, dass sich irgendwie was komplett Neues findet, was dann wieder so zündet, wie das bei Club-Math der Fall war, kann ich überhaupt nicht einschätzen. Es gibt vielleicht noch so ein paar Sachen, wo es noch in die Richtung gehen kann. Es gibt zum Beispiel bzw. auch wieder ein neues Getränk irgendwie, was ursprünglich aus der Sowjetunion gab. Da gab es Bicol hieß das und das war damals halt quasi so die Hackerbrause der Sowjetunion. Da waren irgendwelche psychoaktiven Kräuter drin und das wird gerade oder seit irgendwie einem Jahr oder so gibt es da quasi eine Neuauflage davon. Leider ohne die psycho oder oder auf jeden Fall ohne diese psychoaktiven Substanzen nennt sich hier Vostok. Ist auch so ein Berliner Ding. Also vielleicht geht in die Richtung noch, dass sich da irgendwelche Sachen ausgraben lassen, die wohl ziemlich spannend und ziemlich cool sind.
Also ich kann mir auf jeden Fall noch was vorstellen. Das ist alles irgendwie so eine Modegeschichte und als ich noch ganz klein war, hieß zum Beispiel Tee immer Schwarztee. Also mittlerweile kann man auch über Grüntee kaufen, aber ich glaube da geht echt noch mehr. Also wenn man halt irgendwie sieht, in Japan gibt es irgendwie Kit Kat mit Grüntee-Geschmack und Grüntee-Eis und Grüntee-Makiato und so weiter. Also ein bisschen mehr in Richtung Grüntee würde ich mir auch schon mal wünschen. Vielleicht auch so eine leckere Grüntee-Limmung. Wenn man jetzt mal so im Anhalter blättert, ja auch so ein Buch mit kultigen Nachwirkungen, da gibt es ja dieses schöne Gerät, die Nutri-Matic, die alles Mögliche zusammenbaut. Eine meiner Lieblingsszenen ist, wo Arthur Dent, der Nutri-Matic, nachdem sie auf den Wunsch hin Tee auszuspucken, nur so ein ungenießbares Stück Getränk produziert hat, hat sich irgendwie viel Zeit genommen, dieser Maschine ausführlich alles über Tee zu erklären, Tee-Zeremonien und irgendwie das Klima über den Tee hängen, etc. Kurz ging ja auch auf die Geschichte der Ostasien-Gesellschaft ein und so was. Jaja, dann ist die Maschine ja so intensiv damit beschäftigt, dass sie dann leider so viele Rechnerressourcen vom Hauptcomputer abzog, dass das Raumschiff nicht in der Lage war, sich gegen den nächsten Angriff zu verteidigen. Aber wenn man sich jetzt mal so anschaut, was sich so in der Robotik und auch so in dieser Haus, ich baue mir selbst Robotik, was baut, gibt es denn schon so Ansätze, dann auch wirklich, sagen wir mal, so auf so einer chemischen Basis, sich so seine Getränke zusammenzubauen?
Was es ja tatsächlich schon gibt in die Richtung, sind halt diese tollen, selbstgebauten Cocktailautomaten, wo du unten deine diversen Flaschen Grundsubstanzen hast und die dann quasi den Cocktail richtig zusammenbauen. In die Richtung kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es noch weitergeht und sich jemand quasi da einen Erfüllungsgetänke-Zusammenbau-Automaten irgendwie bastelt, den man dann vielleicht auch selbst programmieren kann.
Es gibt ja im Dezember in Wien die Robo-Exotica, dieses Festival für Cocktail-Robotik, da war jetzt, glaube ich, in den letzten Jahren nicht so sonderlich viel mit so mit koffeinhaltigen Erfrischungsgetränken dabei. Aber ja, das ist letztendlich Lebensmittelchemie, also synthetisch hergestelltes Koffein gibt es jetzt auch irgendwie schon recht lange. Da ist irgendwie noch Spiel nach oben offen und ich denke halt irgendwie Lebensmittelchemie könnte durchaus irgendwie so mit Bio-Hacking oder so auch nochmal ein Trend werden. Also diese ganze Sache mit Molekularküche und so weiter. Vom Hacken ist das nicht mehr so richtig weit entfernt. Also man macht halt technisch etwas mit Dingen, wo dann was bei rauskommt, was man vorher nicht geahnt hätte. Ja.
Du müsstest vielleicht mal brief sagen, ob er nicht Lust hat, einen Marte-Bot zu bauen.
Ja, der Marte-Bot. Ich meine, ich habe ja auch mit Lisa schon mal so über Bio-Hacking gesprochen und da merkt man ja, es ist in zunehmendem Maße möglich, auf so ein Level runterzugehen, den man so bisher nicht hatte. Könnte natürlich potenziell auch nicht ganz ungefährlich sein. Aber ich bin gespannt, was da noch bei rauskommt.
Ich meine, vielleicht muss es ja auch nicht unbedingt beim Koffein bleiben. Vielleicht benutzt sich da noch irgendwie der tolle neue Wirkstoff in irgendwelchen Pflanzen oder sei es durch irgendwelches Bio-Hacking. Ob das dann erlaubt ist, ist natürlich dann die andere Frage, weil irgendwie neue Drogen zulassen, da tut sich ja irgendwie.
Aber ich glaube halt Zucker, Wasser, Koffein, das wird uns auf jeden Fall noch beschäftigen die nächsten Jahre. Ja, die Marthe, die hat uns auch wach gehalten. Ich bin nicht ganz so frisch hier in die Sendung eingestiegen, muss ich sagen. Nicht nur, dass man sich dran gewöhnt ist, ist auch immer wieder erstaunlich, wie ein dieses Getränk auch durch lange Podcasts durchziehen kann. Haben wir denn irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen? Mir fällt nichts ein, was wir...
Mir fällt nichts ein, nein.
Okay, na dann, hackerbrause.de. Wenn ihr also noch Getränke kennt, die auf hackerbrause.de noch nicht besprochen wurden und die ihr vielleicht aus eurem Süd- aus-Asien-Urlaub mit nach Hause genommen habt, oder wenn ihr selber in der Küche steht und schon an der Rezeptur des nächsten großen Hackergetränks braut, dann schickt doch Samples an euch.
Genau.
Ihr habt da auch ein Einfallstor, wo klar gesagt wird, wo es hin soll?
Einfach eine Flasche an die E-Mail hinten dran hängen. Einfach eine Mail schicken, irgendwas beliebiges. hackerbrause.de, net.com, organ.
Über Twitter sind wir auch anmerkbar. Unter Hackerbrause.
Da gibt es dann auch eine Adresse, wo man es hinschickt.
Und dann machen wir das mal klar. Dadurch, dass das alles irgendwie in ganz Deutschland verteilt ist, die Leute, die dafür schreiben, müssen wir mal gucken, an welche Adresse es gehen soll. Ach so, da wird sozusagen ausgelost, wer das Sample kriegt. Im Zweifelsfall kriegst du es jetzt.
Genau, auch wenn der Mensch mit den super kreativen Ideen noch irgendwie ankommt und meint, ja, hier bei mir in der Region gibt es irgendwie zehn Getränke, die ich gerne mal verblocken will, sind wir auch für offen. Wir sind keine geschlossene Gesellschaft, sondern geben auch gerne aufstehenden Talenten die Chance, bei uns irgendwie ihr Stuff loszuwerden.
Und das bezieht sich dann auch auf Kochen und Backen, also es muss nicht auf Getränke beschränkt sein. Vielleicht noch ein bisschen zum Abschluss, jetzt haben wir viel über Getränke geredet und was die Hacker so gerne trinken. Habt ihr euch da auch in irgendeiner Form mit der Essensseite auseinandergesetzt? Ach, also ich bin immer so hin und her gerissen. Einerseits gibt es dieses Klischee von wegen ungesund und halt so diese ganzen Pizza-Burger-Hacker Genau, muss irgendwie sofort knallen, muss entweder zuckerig oder fett sein oder so. Und andererseits, es stimmt halt auch nicht. Also oft sind Hacker dann halt auch Leute, die sich irgendwie für Nischensachen begeistern können und dann halt, ja was weiß ich, entweder völlig auf vegan abfahren oder irgendwie die absoluten Sushi-Experten sind oder sowas. Also nur halt irgendwie Mainstream ist halt nicht so sehr angesagt, sondern entweder ist es halt in der einen oder anderen Art extrem, aber ich glaube dieses, ja, nur sich ungesund ernähren, also da sind auch die meisten Hacker aus meinem Bekanntenkreis mittlerweile echt von abgegangen.
Das ist mittlerweile nur noch Klischee, wenn es jemals keins war.
Ist nämlich alles ganz anders, als man gedacht hat und am Ende gewöhnt man sich eh dran. Ja, Jens, jetzt, das war's, oder? Das war's. Mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr weiteres zu ein, aber ich hoffe, für euch war was...
Das war aber jetzt eine kurze Sendung, da bin ich von dir aber mehr gewohnt.
Ja, naja gut, an mir soll es nicht gelegen haben, so, aber mal auch so ein kleines Häppchen zwischendurch, ja, man muss ja dann auch mal wieder zur Mate greifen können. Und dann war auf jeden Fall sehr schön hier in der Mate-Ebene. Genau.
Vielleicht noch empfohlen Chaos Express Radio Nummer 88.
Jaja, achja, richtig, das ist ja eine Vorgeschichte, die wir gar nicht erzählt haben. Zählen wir die jetzt eigentlich? Na du hast, du hast, was war denn da überhaupt eigentlich, gab es da eigentlich eine Vorgeschichte dazu?
Es gab, es begab sich zu einer Zeit, als der Tim irgendwie ganz lang keine Podcasts veröffentlicht hatte und der jetzt hatte solche Langeweile und dann hat er einen Fake-Podcast gebastelt zum Thema Hackerbrausen. Ja, wer den noch nicht kennt, ist irgendwo, gibt es irgendwo, ist in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Das ist etwas andere Chaos-Rage Express.
Gab es ihn jetzt auch endlich mal in echt.
Dann machen wir jetzt hier Schluss und Prost. Vielen Dank, Jens. Vielen Dank, jetzt.
Prost.
Genau. Macht noch eine neue Warte auf. Und das war jetzt hier die ultimative Werbesendung, wo wir uns mal kein Blatt vor den Mund genommen haben, weil es ist eh egal. Das Getränk wird eh genug gefeiert. Da kommt es jetzt auf diesem Podcast auch nicht mehr an. Gut, das war es. Ich bedanke mich für eure Kommentare und fürs Zuhören. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.
Das gefällt mir.
Naja. So kriegen wir die Geschichte nie zu Ende, Holger.